i feel like y'all have upped the ante
since the last time
i gotta be honest with you i don't
remember being this hot what's going on
everybody for first week feast i'm shawn
evans and you're watching hot ones
a reunion special brought to you by our
friends from field roast the makers of
delicious plant-based meats and cheeses
and today we welcome back to the hot
seat kiki palmer the sequel
she's an actress writer and singer with
more than 50 tv shows and films over the
course of her almost two decade long
career
her latest projects are the new audible
series hit job
and turnt up with the tailors check
those out but first things first another
go round with the wings of death
kiki palmer welcome back to hot ones
sean i'm
literally so thrilled to be with you
again and to get into these wings
because you almost had me but this time
around
you won't come close all right kiki well
we have all brand new sauces for you
today and then i know that you
dabble in the plant-based life and today
we'll be eating field roast classic
plant-based nuggets but before we get
started i'm curious
when you think back on that shoot some
four plus years ago in west hollywood
what stands out to you and then what's
going through your brain now as you
prepare to take on the wings of death a
second time
okay what was going through my mind then
i would say is that i was not that
familiar with the show
so i was like you know really didn't
know what i was walking into
i knew it was like i'm eating hot wings
i didn't know obviously how hot they
were going to be how it really was
and then the other thing i remember is
just how great you were that
conversation was just
live and we had so much fun and i walked
away being like oh yeah
i'm answer this and now coming back i'm
so
happy to be here again and just hang out
with you
okay this is delicious
this is a tasty treat
i love a good nugget me too a good
plant-based nugget
so most people know you as a triple
threat entertainer but in recent years
you've put together
a formidable hosting reel as ringmaster
for the 2020 vmas
and then even getting an emmy nomination
for your work on straight hands sarah
and kiki
what are your biggest interview pet
peeves can you give me one your
biggest pet peeve when you're the one
being interviewed
and then your biggest pet peeve when
you're doing the interview
my biggest pet peeve when i'm doing the
interview
or should i say when i'm being
interviewed
is when someone hasn't done their
research you know when they just kind of
give the same
old questions it's like i get it
sometimes we all phone it in but it's
like come on give me something to work
with like let's actually have a fun
experience and bring something new to
the table
you know i'm always looking for that and
then when i'm the one doing the
interviewing like when i'm interviewing
someone else
you know when people are just giving me
one word it's like don't make me pull
water from a rock sweetie i got a lot of
energy but not that much
but you know so i just i'd be hoping
that people are going to come with some
type of energy that i can work with you
know so we can have a good time i think
that's the really good you know the
the great art of a good interview is
that it's just a conversation you know
so you're always looking to be able to
find that balance
[Music]
i'm ready i definitely know these first
four are going to be good fillers for me
because i didn't really have too much to
eat i wanted to
make sure i was ready for this um
this one has a little sweetness to it
[Music]
okay phil roast so last time you were on
the show we discussed the memification
of kiki palmer which is only grown in
legend in the years since
with baby this is kiki palmer and sorry
to this man becoming some of the most
used idioms on the internet
pound for pound which is your favorite
kiki palmer meme
you know the gag is will always and
forever be a classic it will forever be
a classic
but you know obviously i love baby baby
this is kiki palmer because it's like
you really got to know the internet to
know baby this is kiki palmer when halle
berry tweeted baby this is kinky bomb i
said girl
you're on the nets because she you know
you got to really be in the under layers
of the stuff
to know where baby this is kiki palmer
came from and then to what degree do you
think virality
is something that can be reverse
engineered because sometimes we have
these moments on this show that
break containment and become almost
bigger than the show itself
and then people will ask us like how do
you guys do that and i'll be like
i have no idea i don't decide what the
internet decides to put a crown on and
what it sinks to the bottom
and this is what makes memes so special
is that the audience
chooses they decide what they want to
make a moment create like you know make
something legendary iconic that's why
it's so special you know whenever
you make a mean that somebody ends up
loving and goes around the world or it's
a
moment of you in the specific space and
time
sometimes as an entertainer people feel
so far away from you because of the
guise of the whole thing thing that's
really not real
so it's really special to me when it
when it happens i feel like you know
it's like y'all see me y'all know i'm a
real person i love you guys
[Music]
when is it gonna get crazy on this
lineup so kiki i remember you
you poker faced your way through that
was very important to you that you poker
face that you show that you're tough all
the way through
my guesses will get a break in you
around
six or seven i think oh so you expected
me to break huh
okay we'll see about that sean we will
see we will see about that
so my favorite thing about doing reunion
specials is the opportunity to address
some of the blind spots in our last
interviews so
on this swing we'll just focus on the
kiki palmer cult classics that fans
yelled at us for not talking about
enough the first time
do you remember how to spell pulchritude
the championship word from akilah and
the b and then
bonus points if you know the latin word
that it's derived from
it's derived from the latin word pocare
meaning to be beautiful
and you spell it p u
l c h r i t
u d and like angela bassett said
[Music]
nailed it nailed it i always think about
that at the end
angel's best because they had all the
you know people in the end spell one
letter of the
of the word and in the end angela bass
is just like
[Laughter]
i love her true jacksonvp hits a
nostalgic chord with people that you see
fans clamoring for a reboot and then of
course the theme song was included in
this very popular tick-tock dance
challenge
why do you think that that series in
particular resonates with people so much
even 10 years after it last aired well
obviously i think andy gordon who
created the show he
he wrote an amazing show i mean him and
his crew
dan copeland what they put together sid
ventress all those guys
worked together to make a really fun
show the writing i think was like mature
even though it was for kids it was like
really grounded in truth and i think
that's definitely what made your
jacksonvp
special and then also the fact that she
she was somebody that represented
following your dreams at a young age
i think that's like what a lot of people
cling to i've met people
that come up to me and say you know
you're the reason why i wanted to go to
fit him
you know when i saw true jacksonvp as a
kid i thought
man i could do anything i want to start
my own business and it's so funny
because even though i was playing a
character that was doing that i was also
doing that in my life you know working
at a grown-up job never really knew i
could work this hard
so like i was living true jackson's life
as well and so i think that it was just
about a young girl
it wasn't about struggling which is huge
obviously for black americans it was
just a fun show about a young girl
following her dreams
and what kid doesn't want to know that
their dreams can come true when they're
only 15.
[Music]
devil's that name is a little bit try
hard but
[Music]
okay it's going
little keg very slight
i like the flavor though so here at
first we feast we cheered from the
sidelines when we found out that you'd
be hosting a food competition series on
disney plus
and it seems like cooking is something
that you've really been drawn to
during this lockdown and i have you
pegged as a breakfast person
what's the key can you talk us through
how to make kiki palmer's pancakes in as
much detail as possible oh
honey i thought you'd never ask the key
is making sure that batter consistency
isn't too thick or too liquidy because
if it's too liquidy
you're not going to get that nice rise
you're not going to get that fluffy
middle it's going to be just
you know too crisp which if you want a
little more crepe vibe
go at it but if you want that natural
just um
pancake look make sure that consistency
is right that's the first thing
secondly don't put the eye on too high
you want it to slowly cook that front so
you can get a nice even golden brown
you know what i mean before it burns up
the whole pancake or if
it burns too fast and it doesn't cook
all the way through that would just be a
disaster
right before you put the batter on there
you want to get just one little spray
because you don't want to do too much
oil just
a little spray put the matter on there
let it sit be patient
flip that baby over at the last minute
after it starts bubbling you need to see
the bubbles it needs to pop
pop some bubbles on the back side once
you see those bubbles come through
flip it on over honey and you got
yourself a pancake
[Music]
yeah i want you to know i feel
absolutely nothing
[Music]
this is tasty thank you kiki we'll take
that
all right kinky palmer we have a
recurring segment on our show called
explain that graham where do a deep dive
on our guests instagram pull
interesting pictures that need more
context so i'll show you the picture
you just tell us the bigger story okay i
apologize if this is a painful memory
this is the loss on family feud
who do you pin the palmer family loss on
family my dad dude
my daddy my daddy okay they asked him
what you know he wants on the body what
somebody wants is a delicacy on the body
you know when they get romantic and
stuff
and he had the nerve to say i think he
said
honey or something it was just like
absolutely
ridiculous my mom and i couldn't even
speak
to him for the rest of the evening i
mean we lost to this family that we
didn't even know
bill engvall sorry to this man you know
i would have loved if it was like
the adams family you know anyone the
partridge family
somebody that i know sorry to the family
but
i didn't know them so i really was
devastated by that as well i'm like mama
we couldn't even walk out of here losing
to
steve harvey's family it was devastating
devastating
this one doesn't even look like anything
i feel a little heat trying to creep in
the throat but
nothing you can't handle nothing you
said it
[Music]
it's on your instagram you described an
insane nightmare where coronavirus was
trying to
infiltrate your home by taking on the
form of deceased
family members did you expose yourself
to any of like the
spooky folklore that surrounds new
orleans when you guys were shooting the
horror series scream queens
on location there we definitely did you
know because obviously there's a lot of
tragedy
that has also happened in new orleans so
they have a very you know it's like they
have a tale that
that even though it's paranormal and
seems crazy it also it's
it seems spiritual too it feels very
valid you know that these
souls will still walk and you know
wander this
land and you know tell their want to
tell their story or want someone to feel
their past
um but whenever i get spooked or not you
know go to stuff like that i just as
soon as i get into my house
the lord is with me lord is with me
and i just started talking i was like
god i know i was into some stuff tonight
but you've gotten my back
you've got i just go to that because it
you know i just move it out it's like i
want to know and i just like i'm
curious i'm into it but please don't
kill me
please don't kill me you gotta just
start singing and stuff it helps
got my natural hair out this time around
won't be needing any keratin treatments
yeah i know i know we still owe you one
now don't make me laugh you know i can
get dangerous around these parts
okay i'm fine
doing good i'm trying to tell is kiki
palmer
poker facing or do you have a proclivity
for spicy foods a talent for it
is it something that you're interested
in i love spicy foods
love love love spicy foods
but spicy foods with flavor
because sometimes it's just that wasabi
hot
oh no no so one of the many things
that's happened since we last spoke is
that tick tock blew up and then you blew
up on tick tock and i saw that your
first ever post was to kick
off the dance challenge for your song i
don't belong to you
have you found that tic-tac at all
affects how your music will take off
and even more so does the platform at
all influence even how you approach
lyrics or song structure yeah i mean i
think it could
subconsciously i think you got to be
careful as a creative
to necessarily contort yourself to what
you're seeing but more so see how you
can express yourself within that space
because that's how you're going to be
you know maintain your most original and
that's how you're gonna also
bring something to the table you know
when you embrace
these platforms it makes you a better
artist and it allows other people to
hear your stuff that never usually would
embrace it but you embrace it in your
own way you know don't allow
what other people are doing to define
who you are and what you're gonna do
just say okay
this is their unique way what's my
unique way and have fun with it
all right kiki palmer that time has come
to move on to the eighth spot you're so
far
unbothered
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
whoa okay
it's a crazy one kiki because i'm your
friend don't
act like i can't handle myself from all
these people shot
i'm taken back to that afternoon in west
hollywood
four years ago where kiki is just poker
facing through
it's wonderful it's so it feels good in
here
you know as a reality tv show obsessive
what's been your takeaway from survivor
from following you on twitter it seems
like you've probably binged at least 20
seasons over the course of this lockdown
they need more black people on that show
good grief
i watched 20 season had one black person
each time that's the main thing
and i love that a host he asked some
really good questions
he really gets in too with those people
but these people blow me away
i love the fact that it becomes like a
family of cast members it's just
i love the show it's so good and then i
saw that you actually picked yourself
for a celebrity version of the show have
you ever given the opportunity what
would be your strategy to win
i'm playing a social game all the way
hey what's up what's up what's up how
y'all doing y'all doing you trippin
look i'm gonna tell y'all right now i
really don't know everything with this
stuff but i got y'all back with it
coming like you cool with me
and then when it gets towards them last
things i'm showing them how i know how
to really
hone it in okay i'm pulling from the
inside out i'm going to the back of my
mind with that meditation level of
concentration it's going to come out of
nowhere i'm going to win
every single one of those ones leading
up to the final countdown
and i'm going to take it all home look
my mouth is hot
my mouth is really really really hot
but i'm i'm cool you know i i i
i'm under control
and i'm trying not to laugh too much
because that's when stuff gets all
caught up in there and i don't want to
be like idris
so i'm trying to like i don't want to
hurt myself so i'm just taking my time
and i'm really in the moment you know
i'm really
getting in from that sacral chakra and
i'm like concentrating
it's helping me
[Laughter]
okay yeah yeah
[Music]
um
who cares about this guy no problem
i know i know so you called playing
cinderella on broadway one of the
crowning achievements of your acting
career why was that project in
particular so special to you
[Music]
i'm just laughing because i'm going back
into the moment
you know i'm going back you know to
being on stage and you know it's just
like
i'm just laughing because it's because
it's milk you know it's just milk
[Music]
oh my gosh sean okay
you know why because growing up
i saw brandy play cinderella on the
may for tv version i just never could
have imagined that i could
be a part of something that impactful
let alone on broadway
because broadway as an actor is like the
olympics for
excuse me getting gassy
and um i never thought i could do it you
know i'm just usually like
action and then cut and it's over but
that doesn't that's not how it works
with theater
and stage so for me to get the
opportunity to a
get on broadway and play a character
that
i never knew represented me until one of
my biggest inspirations played her to
know that i could
get to be a part of anything that
impactful
on stage i'll never forget the little
girl was looking up at me
when i came out and did my first solo
moment and she says
mommy that's not cinderella and i was
just like i'm so happy that now she's
gonna know that
it is you know
[Music]
i'm shaking and trembling all right
geeky palmer
this is the last dab we call it the last
dab because it's tradition to put
a little bit extra on the last wing you
don't have to
if you don't want to kiki palmer oh
you're not gonna upstage me though
good lord that last one really started
giving me
a headache okay thankfully
we've reached the finish line though i
can't believe this
oh cheers kiki palmer
cheers you the best
[Music]
okay kiki palmer here we are at the end
of our second
trip our second journey with the wings
of death but before we put a bow on this
episode
i want to hear from some of the
characters in the kiki palmer universe
which have become so popular they've
actually led to an amazon deal so if
you'll humor me
i have some questions for kiki palmer's
alter egos
and i'm just curious what they think of
kiki palmer's performance today okay
is there a southern bell insult that
comes to mind when you think about the
makers of de bomb
geeky that sauce was the bomb but not
that
outfit you look terrible fix your hair
spicy food has gotten really trendy
these days what do you think of the
trend
chelsea barbie taylor hot or not
oh my god i'm such an influencer they're
finally naming things after me
yeah god and then finally i know that
there's always a good kiki
and always a bad kiki on your shoulder
giving you advice
what is the angel saying to you right
now and what is the devil saying to you
the devil is saying show them what you
got and eat the whole last one of that
hottest hot hot week
the good part of me is saying not if you
don't want to be [ __ ] fire later
so i think
i'm gonna go with the bad kiki oh
bad kiki bad sean closing out
another go round with the wings of death
kiki palmer again victorious
running through the gauntlet and
listening
to the devil on her shoulder to keep on
going for more but now kiki palmer
there's nothing left to do but roll out
the red carpet for you my friend
this camera that camera let the people
know what you have going on in your life
[Music]
make sure you go check out turned up
with the tailors and vote for me on the
webbies
and make sure you check out my new
audible series starring myself and pete
davidson called
hijob
[Music]
my mouth is so hot
you guys i gotta calm this down
good grief i owe you drinks i owe your
drinks in williamsburg
you do and i wanted at a rich restaurant
down by where you live
ain't going to know that williamsburg
deal we're going to the city